Speaker 1: Throughout this week, we've been
talking qualitatively about the feeling that
Joe Biden's presidency has turned around.
We've listed the different accomplishments
over the last two, three months and particularly
over the last 3 to 4 weeks.
But we didn't yet have anything quantitative
to answer the question, is there really a
turnaround happening?
Is Joe Biden's approval actually increasing?
And the reason we care about that is not so
much as a curiosity, although it's interesting
to see a president have such a low approval
rating for a while and then see it recover
because it's what tends to happen during presidencies
is there's an erosion of approval over time.
What is interesting about it is its impact
on the November midterms, which are now just
roughly nine weeks or so away by very, very
rough estimate.
Looking at the calendar, if indeed Joe Biden's
approval rating continues to increase at the
rate at which it has over the last ten days,
it is all of a sudden looking very bad for
Republicans in November.
So the first question is, what are the numbers?
Well, Joe Biden's approval rating has spiked
11% in a very short period of time.
Now, for those who may or may not understand
the precision with which I am speaking, 11%
increase is not an 11 point increase.
The approval rating of Joe Biden bottomed
out at 37 and a half right on July 21st.
And it has now gone up to 41.6%.
That is, of course, not an increase of 11
percentage points, but it is an 11% increase
in one month.
That is significant.
And if you see even half or two thirds of
that increase continue until November, you're
going to have a quite popular Joe Biden on
the day of the midterm elections, because
these midterms are, in a sense, referenda
on those in power, which in this case includes
a Democrat in the White House, Democrats controlling
the Senate, although barely, and Democrats
controlling the House.
The conventional wisdom would be that would
be very good for Democrats.
And you can tell that Biden is sort of reinvigorated
in a sense.
He is back on the campaign trail and starting
to be visibly campaigning for Democrats running
in November.
Yesterday, at a rally against a Trump allied
Republican in Maryland, he gave a quite good
speech in which he slammed the MAGA movement
as semi fascism.
And I think that that's a pretty good term.
I sometimes call it wannabe fascism, wet dream,
fascism, authoritarian, you know, wishing
whatever you want to call it.
Joe Biden, back out there.
And listen, these are just empirical questions.
There was the feeling that there was a turnaround.
That turnaround is very much reflected.
This is.
And by the way, if you look.
Even though the number is still under 42%
for Biden's approval, the rate at which it
increased is significant, and we have not
seen that during Biden's presidency so far.
It matches essentially the quickest decline
that we saw in August of 2021 as Republicans
were slamming Biden for the pullout from Afghanistan
and Colbert numbers were not looking good.
This is as rapid an increase as we have seen
a decrease during the Biden presidency, and
we still have time.
But it so far bodes very, very well